hello and welcome back to brain review
my name is Caleb Denby and today I'm
gonna be taking you through a game a
classic game between Mikhail Botvinnik
and Hosea Raul capablanca this was a
game play it all the way back in 1938
and it's very very famous you might be
familiar with it I think it's actually
you know been called an essential and
any person studying of of the classics
and the reason if that is it's very very
instructive in the way that both players
played this was a tournament where it
was nearing the end of Kappa Blancas
career actually he was starting to have
some health problems and perhaps that
contributed to this game but it was a
very very impressive showing nonetheless
by Botvinnik
and let's see how he achieved it the
game started 1 d4 Knight f6 c4 e6 Knight
c3 and Bishop b4 of course going into
the nimzo-indian defense white chose to
play III one of the main lines black
continued with d5 and now after a three
white is forcing black to make a
decision either to capture or to
retreats in this case we see Bishop
takes c3 B takes c3 and after c5 White's
temporary deficiency and his pawn
structure is now solved with C takes d5
and after a takes d5 Bishop d3 castles
92 and b6 we have achieved kind of the
structure of our position for the game
it's a very interesting structure and
it's one that can be achieved a few
different ways in in the nimzo-indian
and generally the the plans for black
lie on this Queen side black wants to
expand on this Queen side and make use
of his pawn majority in order to to
create threats over here and at the
moment for white it might be a little
bit unclear what his plans going to be
but in actuality it all revolves around
this move f3 white wants to play f3 use
this C pawn to support his Center and
then continue with efore expanding in
the center and if white can achieve this
comfortably its
usually going to come with devastating
effect and so the the character of this
game is kind of such that black needs to
play quickly on the queenside because if
you give white too much time then efore
will come he five will come and this
expansion in the center will be
devastating so we'll see how both
players approach this position then
white castle's first of all black plays
Bishop a6
this move is kind of essential to the
opening for black I've seen a lot of
amateur players play a move like Bishop
d7 here thinking that they're indirectly
stopping efore for the moment but really
this bishop is is much more powerful
than its counterpart here on b7 so it
just makes good sense to play Bishop a6
in the game white chose to capture this
Bishop drawing this Knight out to a6
which is perhaps not its favorite square
in the world here white continued with
Bishop b2 this looks like a very very
strange move at first but it makes a lot
of sense once you keep in mind White's
eventual plan for example let's just
play some moves for white here you can
imagine let's say once we play e4 a big
weakness is going to be our D pawn and
so we put this bishop here to support it
a for this eventually for break that's
the purpose of this Bishop so going back
Bishop b2 with the idea of supporting d4
we now see Queen d7 from the black
player josè row will capablanca and now
let's move a four from white and this
one is is it's a pretty interesting
decision from white to play a four it's
always risky kind of when you're playing
moves on the side of the board where
your opponent wants to play it in this
case it turned out to be a very nice
idea as I said blacks idea is to
actually expand on the Queen side moves
like b5 and B four are quite commonplace
here and so with a four you're actually
slowing down that expansion quite a bit
by putting this pressure onto the b v
square so a four a very nice move rook
fe8 white now plays queen d3 eyeing this
knight on a six and black makes the
decision to play c4
and this is a very very committal
decision and it's one that I don't
necessarily agree with and most of the
lines that we're gonna take a look at
today for example let's say night b8 was
played instead perhaps there's a problem
on this square but let's just play
naturally following the plans this night
it's gonna come out to g3 the strut can
come to d8 for example and whenever
white wants to play the move just will
pass whenever white wants to play the
movie for he's always gonna run into
this problem where he doesn't have
enough support for the d4 square and
this is really really important for the
black player by having this pressure on
d4 you can prevent white from playing
efore for quite a long time it's very
difficult actually for white to get
enough support to defend this pawn so
looking back c4 it is very very
committal in the sense that you're
giving up almost all of that pressure on
d4 now the c3 pawn is more than enough
defense for d4 and F 3 and E 4 might
come quite quickly that being said the
game's not over yet we see Queen c2 an
IB 8 this rook actually comes to e1 like
I said supporting the e pawn Knight c6
Knight g3 and now Knight a5 and this is
really where kappa blanka started to
lose the thread of the game I had been
saying this whole time you know it's
it's really important that black plays
quickly on the Queen side or else you
know F 3 and E 4 will come and white
will have a crushing advantage and while
the knight might look nice
coming from a 5-2 squares like b3 it's
it's simply not doing enough what you
need is this pawn coming to be for like
right away or else you're gonna be in
trouble I would have preferred to see a
move like a six even or a move like rook
b8 with the idea being you're gonna open
and open things up on the Queen side as
fast as possible trying to prevent
White's play in the center from-from
kind of crushing there are also options
like Knight e4 this is a good move to
try and delay White's plans white
actually has the very very
though night h1 the idea of playing f3
and bringing this night back out to f2
or even g3 again and now the game cook
might continue with the move like a6
like I was saying and after f3 will say
Knight g5 e for black is expanding on
the Queen side as wide as expanding in
the center so that's how the game should
have gone instead though we do see
Knight a5 and this idea is simply much
too slow white continues with the plan
playing very naturally we see f3 Knight
b3
now e4 the point of this Knight coming
to b3 is that black can pick up this
pawn but now black has spent far too
much time on the Queen side without
creating any definite threats using this
pawn majority so we see a 5 breaking
through tonight comes back to d7 then
why it really takes his time here he
starts with Queen f2 stepping out of any
potential trades black plays g6 white
plays f4 and blacks next movie is pretty
much forced of course if you play some
nonchalant move like Queen c6 f5 is
going to open things up and black will
be checkmated immediately so forced for
black is to play f5 first and then of
course everybody's favorite rule in
chess
black or white does not want to allow
this F pawn to stand he doesn't want to
keep things closed on the Kings side
black has devoted all of his pieces to
the Queen side so now Botvinnik looked
for ways to open things up of course the
best way to do that here is with pawn
takes pawn on Poisson and you might
think at home that this is maybe an
unnatural move and the reason for that
is is you've probably been told
protected pass pawns are very very very
powerful but in this case it's much more
valuable to open up the Kings side to
get at that king where all your pieces
are pointing then to keep a simple
protected past pawn because the fact is
let's say you play some move the fact is
after Knight f8 the what the Black
Knight is going to be perfectly placed
to blockade this epon and your attack is
going to kind of stall for a bit it's
not really clear how you're getting at
that
King so he takes f6 a very nice move a
very instructive move opening things up
on the Kings side we see Knight takes f6
and right away f5 and this is this is
where you really start to feel the
absence of these two pieces all of
whites major pieces and the knight are
well placed attacking this King
let me see rook takes c1 rook takes c1
rook e8 kappa blanka desperately trying
to trade off some of these pieces this
rip comes up to e6 rook takes c6 f takes
c6 the knight is detect so we see q g7
this Queen comes up to f4 aiming at the
c7 square black desperately tries to get
this Queen back into the game but it's
simply too little too late Queen e5
comes Queen e7 comes and now the the key
moment in the game this is why this game
has become a classic there's a very very
nice tactic here for white to just
simply win the game I'll let you try to
find it a home feel free to pause the
video here but this is you know what one
of one of the most fantastic tactics in
all of chess okay of course that tactic
is to attack the King with Bishop a3
this is this is a fantastic move it's
very very instructive once again you see
you see the point of whites play this
black knight is totally side bind on p3
not contributing to the defense at all
and by drawing this Queen away at the
cost of a full Bishop we now have the
excellent follow-up which I'm sure you
all have seen at home but if you haven't
feel free to pause the video again
Knight h5 check and with the absence of
the Queen this is more than enough to
just win the game of course you can't
move the King because will capture the
night and after G takes we have Queen g5
check and no matter where you go we take
this night with check after King g8e 7
checkmate is threatened and of course
Botvinnik had this all calculated I'm
sure you did at home as well Queen I one
check are will start Queens c1 check
King f2 Queen c2 check King g3 Queen d3
check King eh
for Queenie forecheck King takes pawn
and now you can't trade the Queens and
because this pawn does get to promote
this King a very excellent defender of
the h7 or f7 square and instead we see
Queenie to check and after King h4
Queenie for check G for Queenie 1 check
King h5 white is totally safe no more
checks Botvinnik calculated it all the
way to King h5 and here kappa blanka was
forced to resign as there's simply no
way to prevent Queen f8 and e8 from
coming onto the board when why it would
be totally winning and so the reason
this is such an instructive game is
because you see black wastes his time on
the Queen side bringing that night out
to be 3 and then bringing the Queen out
to win upon when in fact you need to
play much more quickly much more
actively play for the plans don't play
to win a side bind pawn that isn't worth
all that much with that in mind thank
you very much for joining me on this
episode of game review my name is Caleb
Denby and I will see you in the next
episode